leur vie est une succession de réussite
d'échecs ou de traverser du désert comme
on dit mais aussi de rebondissements
permanent je pense plus particulièrement
à vous Bernard Tapie l'as déjà dans ce
domaine quel est le moment dans votre
vie quel est le moment dont vous avez
été le plus fier le moment où vous êtes
dit j'ai vraiment j'ai atteint mon but
et à l'inverse quand avez-vous pensé
être fini ne plus faire surface Bernard
Tapie donc je présentais comme le roi
des rebondissements des succès
retentissants et des échecs tout autant
à vous j'ai jamais vécu de moment
tragique au point que parce que parce
que Dieu m'a non mais parce que le seul
élément qui peut vraiment vous anéantir
au point de ne plus y croire c'est la
santé et pour l'instant je vous jure
j'ai été épargné
pas le tempérament de battant que vous
avez puisque vous avez en fait balayer
tous les mauvais souvenirs parce que moi
j'ai gardé en mémoire à un moment donné
vous avez dit je me suis sentie quand
vous avez démissionné de votre poste de
ministre que les ennuis ont commencé il
y avait un titre de journal tapis et
mort et que vous l'aviez ressenti
douloureusement
mais je peux vous raconter tout mais des
convenu mais bon moment mais je vous
assure que c'est pas un numéro je ne les
mémorise pas mais mais plus qu'un autre
non vraiment pas c'est formidable c'est
pour ça que vous vous rebondissez en
permanence
ça m'a pas marqué ma vie en tout cas
quand on vous appelle monsieur le
ministre est-ce que d'abord
mérité beaucoup vous appellent comme ça
beaucoup plus que vous ne le pensez et
souvent non mais comme vous le faites
pas vous c'est qu'on le pense
et jamais et jamais pour se moquer de
après ça j'imagine bien sûr des
allusions comme ça pourquoi parce que je
l'ai pas volé on me l'a pas donné non
plus et j'ai pas laissé de cette période
de ma vie de choses qui soient de
naturel critique
j'ai pas été critiqué sur cette période
de ma vie là autrement dit même dans mes
moments les plus difficiles où j'ai eu
des rendez-vous avec la justice ça n'a
pas été le fait de mon action en tant
que ministre mais on peut pas d'un côté
ne pas mémoriser ces éléments là pour en
faire des moments de satisfaction
intense et être autre chose que
simplement flatter et fier de ce qu'on a
fait quand on nous rappelle les bonnes
choses qu'on a faites même de rêver
d'être président de la République quand
on est en face souvent on veut devenir
non mais souvent on veut devenir
président de la République vous avez dû
penser je crois qu'il y a quelques-uns
en ce moment mais on l'a pensé à un
moment
sérieusement fait la couverture le jour
où ils ont fait ça d'ailleurs ça a été
le début de mes emmerdes je crois je
crois que vous y avez rêvé franchement
non tu dois venir par exemple je crois
que tu as il y a des jours où tu as
pensé c'est normal et ça n'a rien
attends j'en aurai pas honte et je pense
que ceux qui me connaissent savent que
s'il y en a qui assume ses envies et qui
a pas peur de les franchement je serai
moi je dirais la même manière en
politique il y a les figures libres et
les figures imposées moi je pouvais
gagner tout ce qui était figurine mais
dans le cadre des figures imposées
j'avais pas le cursus je me prépare pas
à ça par conséquent non j'ai jamais rêvé
de ça par contre j'avais pas non plus
rêvé d'être ministre franchement pas
donc tout peut venir alors à 61 ans
quand même peu de personnes ont occupé
autant de fonctions on fait autant de
métiers que vous vendeur homme
d'affaires patrons de l'OM ministre
animateur de télévision acteurs et
maintenant comédien c'est quand même
c'est une panoplie absolument absolument
gigantesque est-ce que vous saviez que
vous aviez ce potentiel en vous
mais je pense franchement que tout le
monde a un énorme énorme potentiel c'est
pas le potentiel qui est en cause quand
les gens font rien c'est d'abord souvent
les circonstances de la vie qui sont pas
favorables parce que pour exprimer
toutes ces activités là faut avoir eu un
grand nombre de circonstances qui
étaient favorable ça s'appelle la chance
tout simplement deuxièmement il faut
avoir beaucoup de
culots et le troisième point il faut
avoir eu envie très tôt d'être habitué à
se battre moi 14 ans j'étais charbonnier
tous les étés et quand arrivait à la
rentrée scolaire mes copains faisaient
la gueule moi j'étais heureux parce que
c'était la fin des sacs de charbon que
je manipulais pendant les trois mois des
vacances scolaires donc vous pensez que
c'est ce qui vous a donné
les armes pour vous pour vous battre un
peu pour avoir de l'énergie pour savoir
que rien n'est facile très tôt on va
plus de plus de 25 ans vous avez
commencé on a commencé à entendre parler
de vous à la fin des années au milieu
des années 70
bien je sais pas oui 77 enfin bon voilà
enfin depuis 25 ans avec Léo et les bas
quand même Bernard Tapie d'une carrière
en dent de scie vous avez toujours
occupé moi c'est ce qui qu'est-ce qui
est devant la scène quelque chose chaque
fois qu'il y avait une victoire elle
était toujours et vous regarderez à la
toujours été
à moindre riz ou en tout cas terni par
le doute sur la manière de cette
victoire est arrivée 80 parce que moi
j'ai regardé
si je fume pas je demande le droit de
parler Bernard Tapie non mais vous avez
un carnet la réussite l'autodidacte qui
s'en sort et dans les années
90 une image ternie c'était l'argent
facile à corruption etc la vérité sur
tapis dans le point en quête de
L'Express Nouvel Observateur qui n'est
pas vrai les institutions
et l'autre partie de la France qui
m'aimait bien en disant que j'étais un
escroc en gros
mais ça arrivait quand même pas à me
faire des tester par tout le monde pour
autant ma question j'y reviens donc je
dis vous vous avez pendant plus de 25
ans
occupé la scène que l'on parle de vous
en bien ou en mal vous avez toujours
occupé les médias est-ce que vous le
faites exprès est-ce qu'à un moment
donné vous en avez ras-le-bol j'ai
refusé dans la semaine dernière quatre
émissions majeures à des prime time bon
c'est pour vous dire quoi en réalité
d'hypermarchés c'est-à-dire je suis en
présence dans les têtes de groupe
de gondole quand elle marche et ben on a
envie de les avoir tout le temps dans le
rayonnage une autocritique Bernard
tapica vous dites bien à un moment donné
je suis pas qu'un mec génial j'ai dû
faire deux trois trucs
d'avoir fait certaines choses non c'est
pas ça que je regrette certains trucs
un moment donné d'avoir flambé trop je
vous donne deux exemples mon bateau par
exemple mon bateau jamais tant que je
l'ai eu personne n'a eu le droit de le
voir ni de le visiter il y a jamais eu
une caméra il y en a pas photo mon hôtel
particulier qui a été tant décrit jamais
vous l'avez vu non plus personne n'a le
droit d'y rentrer vous dites que vous
avez peut-être un moment donné c'est
vous qui avez été là je vais vous dire
ce que j'ai fait là j'ai été provocateur
dans la limite où c'est pas un pays
contrairement à ce que l'on croit
souvent vous dites en France on n'aime
pas le succès c'est pas vrai c'est pas
le succès qu'on aime pas
c'est le c'est l'exposition du bonheur
il faut pas paraître heureux et la vraie
le vrai dit ton populaire pour vivre
heureux faut vivre caché c'est pas
cacher ses performances on voulait
tolère vous êtes des gens comme Pinot
Arnaud qui réussissent des choses
fabuleuses mais qui donne pas deux
l'image de mec heureux moi un moment
donné c'était tout much c'était
insupportable il est président de l'OM
il est ministre il a acheté Adidas il a
un bateau il pilote son avion il
voudrait pas qu'on l'aime en plus non
sans être démago là c'est non mais
Bernard Tapie je suis d'accord mais là
c'est un peu facile je vous ai entendu
dire un moment donné quand même
je comprends qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes
remonté à bloc mais
pour autant je vous ai entendu dire non
ça sera refaire je pense que j'aurais
quand même une réussite moins éclatante
un moment donné je pense quand même
qu'on pète les plans qu'on ne sait plus
trop ça c'est des raisons de l'échec
c'est que numéro 1 autour de vous
l'esprit critique ces mousse beaucoup et
non pas parce que ce sont des gens qui
vous lèchent les pieds c'est parce que
vous leur avez donné trop souvent
l'habitude d'avoir raison et donc dans
un conflit quand il y a pas l'accord
ils amenuisent leur esprit critique on
les embrassi ils le dis c'est sûrement
vrai or c'est pas vrai
et deuxièmement on croit qui peut plus
rien vous arriver à tout point de vue et
y compris alors là je l'avoue très
humblement
le fait de ne pas croire que l'échec est
possible mais on entend plus personne
vous avez vu la gestion de certains
éléments tout le monde a vu ces
dernières mois tel homme politique
gérait mal un truc hôtel on est
tellement lucide quand il s'agit de la
des problèmes des autres Bernard Tapie
je vous interromps
les journaux télévisés ont ouvert
pendant 2 jours sur des camions qui
rentraient chez moi qui déménageaient
mes meubles mais lustres qui les
emmènent on l'a vu tout le monde s'en
souvient au moment où vous avez été donc
passé le crayonnais a été condamné à
nous rendre les meubles ils ont il a été
prouvé par la justice il y avait aucun
droit dessus ils ont fait appel ils ont
perdu en appel ils sont allés en
cassation ils ont perdu en cassation
jamais il y a eu une ligne alors encore
moins la télévision il y a même jamais
une ligne pour l'indiquer on a indiqué
que j'avais fait des faux tableaux on a
indiqué que j'avais déménagé mes meubles
dans la nuit vous avez vu ça j'ai eu un
non lieu là-dessus ça n'a jamais été
indiqué donc ils ont une telle faculté
de manipuler l'image que faisons
attention avant de juger les gens qu'on
connaît pas à ne pas être un peu
manipulé à notre tour est-ce que quand
on joue les médias comme ça quand
justement en instrumentalise les médias
forcément parce que on en fait le
vecteur de sa réussite de ses affaires
de son image est-ce que est-ce qu'on est
pas condamné à être tué par les premiers
risques
quelque chose c'est vous qui êtes
demandeur c'est pas c'est pas une raison
c'est pas la preuve mais vous pouvez pas
résister quand Monsieur Jean-François
Cannes appelle un chef d'entreprise et
qui lui dit je vous envoie monsieur
safran pour faire une biographie de
quatre pages si vous dit non vous faites
quoi vous la faites quand même c'est
vous qui avez l'initiative du choix pas
nous jamais
c'est très bien que ça se passe pas
comme ça je voudrais juste te dire quand
même quelque chose là vous avez raison
c'est que quand on joue au feu quand on
joue avec les médias on joue au feu on
se brûle on risque d'être tué pour
autant c'est vrai et là ce n'est pas
Bernard Tapie qui le dit n'importe quel
anonyme qui se trouve condamné le dit
souvent en en général il a une
condamnation il est placardisé dans un
journal et il a un non-lieu il ressort
etc
non mais même pour les anonymes il y a
juste une ligne dans les journaux tout
le monde s'en plaint pourquoi c'est
comme ça pourquoi c'est toujours le
scandale qui qui prime finalement sur un
moment donné l'erreur c'est la fameuse
histoire des tringles c'est à dire
qu'évidemment le quelqu'un qui est mis
en cause par la justice au consulte et
ben c'est une information plus forte que
le fait que bah trois ans après parce
que ça se passe trois dans quatre ans
après on en parle plus on ne sait plus
de quoi il s'agit faudrait rappeler
l'histoire alors bon voilà c'est c'est
tout à fait dommageable c'est même
scandaleux mais oui c'est c'est un fait
un moment donné s'il est arrivé tout ça
c'est que à force de racheter
différentes entreprises vous vous disiez
je vais les sauver à l'époque vous avez
une idée même une émission qui
s'appelait ambition
c'est ce que disait Guy Bedos qui par
ailleurs vous trouvez poustouflant mais
il dit quand même un moment donné il a
fait beaucoup d'argent pour d'autres
c'était pour votre propre projet
que j'étais une ordure car quand vous
quand vous prenez une entreprise comme
Adidas 12000 personnes perdez un
milliard par an vous devez les réduire à
6000 pour arriver à être concurrentiel
mais je peux vous dire que les 6000 qui
se retrouvent sur le pavé même si vous
leur expliquez en long en large en
travers que c'est pour conserver la
boîte même si vous faites les plans
sociaux tout ce que vous voulez il vous
prennent pour un qui leur a
coûté leur emploi même si évidemment je
les connaissais pas à titre personnel
c'est les seuls qui ont le droit de dire
c'est un parce que j'avais un
boulot j'étais à tel endroit en Alsace
j'ai perdu mon boulot sauf que bon pour
en sauver 10 000 il fallait parfois
est-ce qu'il vous est arrivé de vous
dire là il faut que ça s'arrête je
voudrais que ça s'arrête je sais c'est
trop est-ce que vous l'avez pensé
j'avais pas le sentiment de de j'avais
pas le sentiment d'être en dehors des
clous voilà ce que je veux dire si vous
savez dans les rebonds tout à l'heure
vous avez vous avez parlé de la prison
moi j'ai fait huit mois et alors j'ai
vraiment vu quelque chose de
d'absolument net et si un jour vous
voulez bien analyser ça vous allez voir
le juge qui vous tue qui vous met du
remord qui vous empêche de rebondir qui
vous fait devenir une épave c'est votre
conscience
[Musique]
j'ai pas l'impression j'ai pas
l'impression que ça soit une chance mais
ça m'a pas parce que c'est un moment de
faire le pour faire le point
je suis malheureux j'ai pas fait mais je
suis belle pas du tout quand vous êtes
en prison je parle sur le contrôle de la
colère c'est qu'il n'a pas été là
avec l'autre quand il était en prison
vous êtes un amuseur public depuis des
années
vous voulez des choses qui viennent
d'être
dites et qui dépassent quand même un peu
les bornes
à Mireille Dumas
vous nous parlez des médias les médias
ils vous ont tapé sur la gueule
somptueusement
lorsque vous avez été condamné
vous avez été condamné je tapis les
médias c'est eux qui vous ont fait
mais c'est eux qui vous en fait les
médias vous ont fait
un jour après ils vous ont défait mais
bien sûr
quand vous nous parlez ensuite de la
prison
avec en disant que ça vous a rien appris
et qu'on pense pas dans sa petite
cellule etc bon je trouve je trouve
votre réaction d'une extrême légèreté et
je la trouve insultante pour un certain
nombre mais je suis désolé monsieur le
ministre vous pouvez très bien
bénéfique vous dites et je pose la
question donc à Gérard Poitiers
Jean-François Kahn vous dit d'abord
Bernard Tapie est une construction des
médias ils vous ont fait c'est normal
qu'il vous défasse vous pensez ça aussi
j'ai pas dit que c'était normal que les
médias ont tendance à lyncher ce qu'ils
ont contribué
est-ce que ce sont les médias qui ont
fabriqué
le beau palmarès personnel il a rien à
voir avec la manière dont vous les avez
raconté que vous soyez le relais c'est
exactement comme demain vous dites
Zidane c'est une construction médiatique
Zidane vous le construisez pas il est le
meilleur footballeur du monde et vous
lui donnez qu'au mais c'est pas la
construction de Jean-François Kahn qui a
fait gagner Marseille en Coupe d'Europe
ou une autre de France ça correspond
la vérité c'est que ils utilisent c'est
c'est vrai tapis c'est vrai de tous les
bonnets voilà et plus lui pas pour la
raison vous a dit parce que il y a pas
je ne connais pas au monde depuis très
longtemps quelqu'un qui a eu l'aventure
l'histoire les rebonds qu'il a eu c'est
un cas pour votre émission il y a pas
d'autres cas que lui avec
évidemment les médias se sont précipités
là-dessus il faut le dire l'ont utilisé
utilisé pour faire de l'écoute pour
faire des côtes etc et en même temps il
s'en voulait et donc parce qu'il se sent
voulait de l'avoir utilisé comme ça
finalement ils se sont punis en le
punissant je crois qu'il y a un truc
absolument pervers
ce sont lavés de l'or culpabilité
c'est qu'il y a une époque les années 80
était une année où il fallait montrer
que vous pouvez redécouvrir les
créateurs les entrepreneurs donc on
avait besoin d'un héros il se trouve
qu'il y a eu un personnage qui est
arrivé là si ça avait pas été lui il y
en a eu un autre peut-être qui sera paru
mais il est arrivé et puis il a été pris
par par la vague qui montait alors moi
je voudrais revenir à ce moment de la
prison vous dites finalement
finalement je n'ai je n'ai rien appris
j'imagine que vous en êtes sortis
différents quand même Bernard
que je pleure écroulé dans le camion le
premier soir ça va je ne suis pas en
train de vous dire
c'est comment
je ne suis pas sorti différents voilà
permettez-moi de vous dire ça pas du
tout qu'est-ce qui fait qu'un moment
donné quand vous pensez comme ça ça vous
traverse l'esprit au suicide c'est dans
votre livre que vous en parlez
oui mais vous y repensez une fois en
prison très très rapidement qu'est-ce
qui fait que justement dans ces
moments-là on voilà c'est une pensée
qu'on évite à mon avis enfin je crois je
crois que ça dépasse le cadre de la de
la gestion personnelle
de sa de son destin de la même manière
que
le Scorpion se tue quand il sent qu'il
est prisonnier au bout d'un moment ça
arrive pour certains bouts d'une semaine
d'autre au bout de trois mois mais il y
a un moment où votre physiquement vous
ne supportez plus l'enfermement
c'est-à-dire que on est on est dans une
situation de détresse totale et donc la
lutte c'est entre la survie qui vous
donne envie parce que les avocats parce
que parloir parce que les courriers vous
raccrochez et l'envie d'en finir parce
qu'on supporte plus de ne pas être
capable de gérer son destin pour le la
moindre des choses aller prendre une
douche ou faire autrement dit vous savez
que vous n'êtes plus rien d'autre que
l'incarnation de la volonté des autres
mais plus votre volonté vous avez
échappé à votre contrôle et à votre auto
contrôle et donc là moi c'est le moment
où j'ai le plus souffert quand vous êtes
sortis de prison vous étiez animé par
quoi en sortant
je vais revenir je vais prouver je vais
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit
sortez de prison l'essentiel c'est de
retrouver le goût d'aller épicer contre
un arbre de prendre un vélo et de faire
une heure dans les bois de moi je suis
revenu avec mon petit-fils qui avait 10
ans et on a fait d'une traite
à Aix Paris en voiture ça a été un
voyage le plus beau voyage de ma vie
moi aussi il y a un moment où on fait le
complexe du Comte de Monte-Cristo c'est
à dire que tout à coup au bout de
quelques temps dit bon alors maintenant
je vais prendre ma revanche je vais les
avoir je vais me venger je vais je vais
le remontrer que etc est-ce qu'il y a un
moment non regardez-moi ça un moment
donné Claude Lelouch et Philippe
percette du temps de la main pour pour
devenir acteur comédien et vous y allez
avec le doute ou c'est là où je vais en
arriver parce que j'ai le sentiment que
vous partez c'est ça qui est absolument
qui fascine tout le monde vous partez
dans les aventures sans doute en vous
disant j'y vais et quel est le justement
ce culot cette chose qui vous dit j'ai
pas le choix jusqu'au moment où il me
propose ça j'ai plus le droit de faire
d'affaires j'ai plus le droit de voter
plus de football plus de la faire plus
de politique plus rien et puis je vis de
quoi je vis il faut que je vive et donc
comme j'ai pas de cagnotte et que malgré
les investigations nombreuses et longues
ils ont pas trouvé parce qu'il y en
avait pas donc il faut que je vive et
comme j'ai plus le droit de faire aucun
des métiers qui jusqu'à présent manouri
la vérité c'est que quand on propose de
faire du théâtre je sais pas si je vais
être capable ou pas de le faire mais ce
que je sais c'est que c'est un moyen que
je vais avoir de survivre et il se fait
que j'y prends du plaisir et que
apparemment mon producteur en est
heureux et ça fait un carton là en ce
moment ça marche très fort avec un beau
et moi ce que je trouve
absolument incroyable c'est là encore je
dis vous êtes quand même gonflé vous
interprétez une pièce qui s'appelle un
beau il faut quand même le porter
déjà et
bien sûr puisqu'il trahit toutes les
femmes il est assez démago et tout et
vous vous assurez ça avec au contraire
vous en même puisque vous êtes dans la
vie
totale là tu racontes
que tu fais et tu as raison là si tu dis
puisque j'ai une image puisque
pour comme tu l'as dit pour les gens qui
m'aiment pour les gens qui n'aiment pas
je suis un autant profiter
puisque j'ai les problèmes etc et je
vais et naturellement je vais en faire
un rôle je vais rendre crédible rose
et tu sais pas à quel point tu as raison
puisque les monologues je les ai réécris
en me rajoutant sur le personnage tous
les défauts que certains me prêtent et
qui me font me jubiler et Jean jouis
pourquoi parce que à la raison sur le
plan de mon comportement barital je suis
le contraire de ça au moins tu peux au
moins me rendre cette grâce c'est où
c'est vrai ou vous avez jamais trouvé le
contraire bon donc je dis je le joue je
le joue parce que je ne me suis pas
j'ai un autre exemple j'avais une
journaliste
à l'événement du génie qu'il connaît
très beau il la déteste une très bonne
journaliste une jeune Villeneuve
sur lui très violent plutôt hostile très
violent or elle avait rien a priori
contre lui etc mais elle a elle a été
amenée à faire un livre très violent
parce que elle ressentait elle avait
l'impression qu'il ira bien un machisme
bestial voilà en fait je te jure elle
ressentait et au fond c'est ça qui l'a
conduit mais c'est vrai je dis pas
qu'elle a quel bon alors comment tu
réagis à ça
je n'ai jamais connu une femme jamais
dans mes amis ou les amis de mes amis
etc qui m'est donnaient le sentiment de
me prendre pour un machiste jamais mais
je te jure que le type qui a des
maîtresses ou qui cavalent les filles il
peut pas jouer ce rôle là tellement il
est odieux c'est assez excellent acteur
excellent comédien à tout le monde peut
prendre du recul vous êtes quand même un
grand charmeur quand même même moi qui
ne vous aime pas profondément je dois
dire quand même que vous avez un charme
c'est un don public
Guy bedo je vous signale il disait en
parlant de Bernard Tapie que même en
prison pour on aurait pu lui confier les
clés pour faire les courses pour les
copains pour exprimer la fascination
justement
[Rires]
contre Monsieur Bernard Tapie qui ne m'a
jamais rien fait auquel je n'ai jamais
rien fait donc j'ai rien contre vous
personnellement je dis simplement que
nous sommes pas sur la même planète
ah bah oui alors on se retrouve
[Musique]
moi avant tout je suis croyant mais
parce que je suis pas obligé
me montrer quand je vais à la messe le
dimanche matin mais je suis d'abord
croyant ben là je vois Jacques Dupuis là
vous le regardez regardez vous attendez
mon cher Bernard parce que là vous êtes
en train de devenir sur ma planète
si vous avez la foi et que vous êtes une
ordure vous pouvez pas sortir de prison
ADEME vous sortez vous êtes fracassé
oui je me mets plus tard
si vous rentrez dans ma loge il y a un
Christ qui est là comme ça je peux pas
jouer si je voilà
prison qui vous avez
ramené à la fois
j'ai eu des parents qui n'étaient pas
croyants et qui avait l'intelligence
d'accepter l'idée que leur fils pouvait
pas avoir les mêmes croyances que vous
êtes fondamentalement
et c'est ce qui explique tout votre
parcours vos herbes ravages vos
provocations permanente parce que dans
le fond vous êtes un brave type
et on a vu en direct
au cours de l'émission un certain nombre
d'actions ce que je comprends pas c'est
qu'un type comme vous
pas mal dans le fond et qui avait qui
croyait pourquoi est-ce que vous croyez
toujours obligé d'en faire trop d'en
rajouter et finalement de créer votre
propre rejet non de vous quoi
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]